- [Narrator] This is the USS Louisiana.
It's one of the Navy's
current 14 nuclear-powered
ballistic missile submarines.
This is China's version, the Type 094.
It's one of the nation's
six nuclear-powered
ballistic missile submarines.
These submarines serve the same purpose.
They are a sort of insurance policy
in the event of a nuclear attack.
But to do its job, each
of these submarines
has to do one thing really well: hide.
(light music)
We compare the Ohio class
submarines' technical capabilities
and missiles with the Jin classes
to see which comes out on top,
and take a look at what
each country has in store
for the future of these nuclear-powered
ballistic missile submarines.
(fanfare music)
On June 9th, 1959, a
decade into the Cold War,
the United States launched this submarine,
the USS George Washington.
It was the Navy's first nuclear-powered
ballistic missile submarine.
These SSBNs are nuclear-powered,
carrying nuclear missiles,
and are one arm of the US
military's nuclear triad,
which includes intercontinental
ballistic missiles,
ballistic missile submarines,
and bombers.
And for the United States,
SSBNs became a crucial part
of its nuclear triad because
of their survivability.
That is, their ability to remain safe
from anti-submarine warfare,
and, if needed, launch
missiles past enemy defenses.
In fact, SSBNs are the most
survivable arm in the triad.
So in the 1980s, the first Ohio class
nuclear-powered ballistic missile
submarine entered service.
The Ohio class, still active today,
was the Navy's sixth generation of SSBNs.
18 submarines in this class were built
over the next 16 years,
though four were later converted
into cruise missile submarines.
As these Ohio class SSBNs were procured,
China was building its first
ballistic missile submarine,
the Type 092, which became
operational in 1983.
They only fielded one, but
it marked a turning point
in China's nuclear capabilities.
A few decades later, in 2006,
satellite imagery spotted the
next generation, the Type 094.
In its 2022 annual report,
the Department of Defense says
China has six operational
Jin class submarines
running deterrence patrols.
But these Type 094s are much
noisier than the 1970s era
Soviet nuclear submarines.
- And that would can safely say undermine
the overall survivability
of the Chinese submarines,
and therefore undermines
the overall credibility
of a sea-based nuclear deterrence.
- [Narrator] Dr. Tong
Zhao has been researching
China's nuclear capabilities
and strategic security issues
for about a decade.
The Ohio class submarines
are capable of carrying
up to 24 missiles,
but to comply with the New START treaty
only 20 are allowed to be carried.
In contrast, the Jin class submarines
can only carry up to 12 missiles.
And like each submarine survivability,
the missiles they carry
are also critical factors
in each military's strategy.
The Navy's SSBNs have held
a variety of missiles.
Today, the Ohio class
submarines carry this missile,
the Trident II.
It's 44-feet long, has
an 83-inch diameter,
and weighs 130,000 pounds.
That's about the weight
of five school buses.
Although the Trident II can
carry up to eight warheads,
it likely carries only three or four
to comply with the New START treaty.
But most importantly, it has a range
of about 4,000 nautical miles.
And since 2017, the Navy has
been updating these missiles
to extend their life and
increase their range even more
to about 6,480 nautical miles.
The Department of Defense says
that China's Jin class
submarines carry either the JL-2
or its next iteration, the JL-3.
The JL-2 has one warhead,
while the JL-3 has multiple.
The JL-2's range is estimated to be about
3,780 nautical miles,
and the JL-3's range reaches
at least 5,400 nautical miles.
This means that from China's shores,
the JL-2 has sufficient range
to target Guam or Alaska.
But the JL-3 might
target the continental US
from areas near China's coast.
But,
- Even if you put
a longer range missiles on
the Jin class submarines,
it's still the Jin class
submarines. (chuckles)
They're still as noisy as the old ones.
- [Narrator] Hans Kristensen
has studied the status
of American nuclear
weapons since the 1980s.
And since noisiness impacts
an SSBNs survivability,
it makes it harder for China's submarines
to travel further from the
shores without being detected.
- Even if you get longer range,
that range is not sufficient to cover
all of the continental United States,
unless you sail far into the Pacific.
- [Narrator] And that's also difficult
for China's submarines to do
because of US anti-submarine defenses
across the Pacific Ocean.
- A sea-based nuclear
capabilities is one area
in which China still lags
behind the United States
in a very significant manner.
China understands that eventually
nuclear submarine may be
the most survivable part
of a country's nuclear arsenal.
So China had this long-term vision
to eventually acquire very advanced
nuclear submarine technologies.
- [Narrator] So what's China
working on to close the gap?
China is expected to begin construction
on its next generation
of SSBN, the Type 096,
in the first part of this decade.
These submarines will run with
the existing Jin class ones,
and experts like Dr. Zhao
say that the Type 096
will be quieter than its predecessor.
But the US is forging ahead, too.
Construction on the
next generation of SSBNs
is already underway.
These Columbia class
boomers will be even bigger
than their predecessors.
- This thing about the
modernization cycle,
you know, they don't
happen at the same time
in China and the United States.
So there's sometimes sort
of a simplistic tendency
or a temptation in the debate
for nuclear advocates to say,
"See, they're modernizing, we're not.
Therefore, we're behind."
But now we have actually,
now we're entering our modernization cycle
and that will run for the
next two to three decades.
- [Narrator] The Ohio class submarines
are reaching the end of their lifetime.
In just a few years, the
first of its generation,
the USS Ohio, will retire.
By 2040 they are set to be
replaced by Columbia class SSBNs.
The Navy is acquiring 12 new SSBNs
and each one will have
room for 16 missiles,
eight less than the
Ohio class could carry.
Cutting back might seem counterintuitive,
but the US military
estimates no more are needed
to meet nuclear deterrence requirements.
And the US Navy says the
Columbia class submarines
will be even quieter.
That's because they're being built
with an electric drive propulsion train
versus the traditional
mechanical drive system.
So even if China's Type
096 is considerably quieter
than its predecessor,
it could be far less stealthy
than the US' upcoming Columbia class.
- So we may see some
incremental improvements.
That doesn't mean that China will be
at the same technical level
with this American counterpart.
(light music)